The joe rogan experience.
So we live in strange times.
Greg Proops.
It's amazing,
isn't it?
Exciting part is like I'm ready for a lot of the old stuff to go away.
Yeah.
I think,
uh,
I mean I have tradition,
obviously I write with a piece of paper and a pen.
Do you really?
Yeah.
I feel like I can't write as fast that way,
so the ideas slip away from me,
but I do write it down before I go on stage because when,
especially new stuff,
I feel like if I don't physically write it down with a pen and a paper,
I don't remember it the same way.
I,
that's exactly what I was going to say,
Joe.
I've done a survey of every comic of talked to him the last two or three years.
Every club I played,
I make everybody get their book out and show me how I go.
Where do you keep your ideas and everybody?
Yeah.
Book a little book with your lists on it.
Mine minor on hotel rooms,
stationary.
Thousands of them,
thousands of pieces of paper I write and I say,
why do you do it that way?
Do you ever write it on your phone?
Yeah.
Uh,
if I think of a one line,
then I ride it,
you know,
did it today.
But do you write your Heloc to the phone?
No.
In the end I have to put it on a piece of paper in red and I just think it's a
mental,
yeah,
that's the really old fashioned part of performing.
I have a note lists of set lists on my phone,
but I'll go to like right before I go on stage sometimes if I want to make sure
that I remember some new shit that I'm working on.
But when I write I go,
when are you going to that luck trance?
I can do that so much better when I'm typing because I can,
the,
the words just appear like I can type a word in a second,
whereas it takes,
but can you remember if you type no,
but I can write better so I get the trance out and I can get more information
out as I'm writing.
But then I go back and I'm like,
fuck it.
Right.
That I remember writing that.
Like I'll,
I'll laugh at some of my own shit and then I'll go,
okay,
I got it.
That I've got to keep that part.
Cause I don't even remember writing because that'll have five hours of writing.
How much do you actually remember?
But the act of actually scribing it into a paper,
a piece of paper.
There's something about that that's like,
it just really like,
it just stores in your memory that's like,
it's like a,
we humans have been doing it that way for so long.
It's like
it's been five,
seven,
10,000 years since people started writing.
Yeah.
I think it,
there's a real profound connection with the paper.
Yeah.
Have you ever thought about releasing those?
Like with your,
um,
like with a special,
like when you release a special release your notes as well.
Wow.
No,
I haven't.
One time I did a fun article for Filter magazine.
The guy came over to me and he said,
how do you,
he saw me fumbling with my notes and I said,
it's all different pieces of hotel stationary.
So I asked my wife to pick it and he goes,
well that will be the article.
Just I want a picture of these,
you know,
notes atlas.
And uh,
I said to my wife,
you pick it out.
I give her the folder full of shit.
So she picked out four random ones.
It was one from like,
Paris went from Minnesota,
one from one place.
I didn't remember being terrible and somewhere,
you know,
and then there was another one and then it just sad like Clinton,
uh,
you know,
corn,
whatever the fuck was on the list,
the Olsen twins and I kind of went through the list as the article.
I just went like,
yeah,
I was doing Clinton jokes in Paris,
you know,
I,
well I think I slept.
Really,
it's always 92 when I rock the Mike Rock,
dumb luck or whatever,
you know,
like,
uh,
that there is a weird insight into kind of like what's going on.
Exactly.
Then with all your setlist cause the different notes you make on them and stuff.
I don't know that there's a that much to be garnered from,
I mean,
I could probably remember some of the debts and stuff like that.
So just something that might be cool.
Like if I was a fan and I got it.
Yeah,
yeah,
definitely.
Just see my old song,
I put it up on design or something.
If you just put the photos online.
Well you ever see that?
A website called letters of note?
No.
Uh,
and there's another one,
something of note.
Um,
but letters of notice letters people wrote to each other or even,
oh,
I think there's one called lists of note.
And um,
the list of note is just different lists that famous people wrote or anybody you
know,
notable.
Like the one I remember is Thelonious monk,
cause I read it on my show at the monk,
you know,
uh,
he had different mental problems and stuff.
You know,
if you've ever seen him play like he played and then he started to get up and
walk around the stage,
you know?
Yeah.
And he's extraordinary.
And then he was given drugs and they didn't quite work out.
But anyway,
he's a genius.
And he could both compose and arrange and extemporize and his band was,
you know,
of
putting the position of having to deal with his,
his personality,
right?
Like,
cause he wasn't like a regular guy who,
who,
hey,
let's,
you know,
I'll be there at five,
he had to kind of be pushed around to places,
but then when he could play was so he wrote a note and on the net it's just how
do we address tonight,
sharp as possible.
Underlined.
Right.
And then,
uh,
if you're,
the drummer I think is something,
you know,
like there's all this like really broken down,
like the thoughts you have before you go on stage.
Like about the band and how he wanted the band to play and look.
And I would,
I would read that out sometimes.
And so I would say on the show,
how do we adjust tonight?
Sharp is possible.
Oh yeah.
Right.
So there's lists of note and there's letters of note.
And then at the last letter of note,
someone sent it to me,
uh,
was,
um,
Jackie Robinson went to a luncheon or a dinner at Ike was speaking at,
right.
And Jackie was an executive.
Yeah.
Jackie Robinson was an executive at chock full of nuts.
Coffee,
right?
Like he got a job in the corporate world because he was an intelligent,
capable and famous person.
He became an executive,
a chocolate nuts in New York and show he went to this like banquet and
Eisenhower Spec and it was a lot of black people there who are in business and
Eisenhower said,
you've got to be patient,
right.
You'll chime will come and all that.
This is the city's.
Wow.
So Jackie wrote him a very respectful letter,
but also very pointed about your patients.
You know,
and I'm not doing it any justice.
It was just,
you know,
Jim,
Mr President,
having recently attended the lunch,
or I have to say that on behalf of myself and my race,
the time for patients is long pass.
You'll find that over the past several hundred years we've endured,
but countless indignant,
you know?
Right,
right,
right.
And then the repository is the next letter.
Eisenhower wrote him back,
do you Mr. Robinson,
thank you for your letter as I take on board what you said and I profoundly,
you know,
Blah Blah Blah.
I'm like,
Oh wow,
this exchange in a very civil and high faluting language,
not the language that we use now,
but like formal letter writing language,
uh,
with the idea of very explicitly expressed that he no longer had the patients to
wait,
that he felt that why shitty weight.
Right.
And why should you have to go to a dinner with the president,
told him to wait when even the first fucking black guy in the big leagues and
they get a job and fucking business and you know,
trying to run his life and shit.
Right.
Yeah.
And Eisenhower like,
he will,
you know,
one day schools will be integrated and you want to have to drink it another
faucet and you know,
you don't want to hear that.
And so those kinds of letters I think to me are like fascinating.
Yeah.
So letters you've known enlisted node are quite good.
If you want to just,
you mean you don't have to read everything on it,
but it's,
it's different letters to people and to that's fucking bad ass.
Yeah.
I will check that nobody writes letters anymore.
In,
in future it will be your setlist of note and your emails of note and your blog
of note the probably be a letter.
Yeah,
it's going away.
The physical act of writing is going away.
If I didn't have to write my set lists down or occasional like fill out a form,
like when I go to Canada or something like that,
I wouldn't,
I don't really write anything.
I do.
I mean,
I read it,
I write on my computer,
but I write in a book too because it's fun.
You're a fucking human being.